matin des quatre coins du colorado ils
sont venus acclamer leurs idoles tony
robbins le super gourou du développement
personnel comme on dit aux états unis et
ce jour là tony robin se réunit dix huit
mille personnes qui ont payé jusqu'à 300
euros pour participer à une méga
convention exaltée par l'ambiance entre
grands messes et concerts rock
les fans de tony robbins viennent
chercher les clés du succès du pouvoir
et de la fortune
pas étonnant lorsque l'on sait que les
plus grandes personnalités font appel à
lui
tony robbins et le coach de nelson
mandela de bill clinton il l'avait été
également avec mère teresa après trois
mois de négociations intenses tony
robbins a accepté de nous ouvrir les
portes de sa machine à motiver les
foules
bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour denver avant tout comment ça va
aujourd'hui je suis très heureux d'être
avec vous parce que ce que nous allons
faire nous allons nous concentrer sur
comment obtenir des résultats et il ne
s'agit pas d'être gonflé et motivés
personnellement je ne crois pas à la
pensée positive la pensée positive c'est
comme aller dans son jardin et dire il
n'y a pas de mauvaises herbes il n'y a
pas de mauvaises herbes il n'y a pas de
mauvaises herbes
c'est de la connerie je pense que pour
obtenir des résultats il faut que vous
ayez une qualité première
avoir deux influences et sur qui devait
beau avoir de l'influencé en premier si
le sou c'est ça sur vous même
[Applaudissements]
la majorité des gens ne sont pas riches
pas heureux ne connaissent pas la
réussite non pas une super famille et
des enfants dont ils sont fiers
la majorité des gens souffrent se bat ou
encore pire a renoncé à se battre
moi je m'élève contre ça aujourd'hui je
n'ai qu'une journée à consacrer à ces
gens semé dans d'autres programmes on
sait ça sur plusieurs années ici je leur
donne juste les bases techniques pour
qu'il change de psychologie c'est la
psychologie qui fait la différence entre
les gens ce ne sont pas les aptitudes il
y a plein de gens qui ont beaucoup de
talent et qu'il ne les utilise pas parce
que leur attitude dans la vie est
désastreuse dois je me charge de changer
ce processus je les sers grandir vous
n'y croyez pas moi je doute que vous
puissiez être là où vous êtes si vous
avez tous accepter passivement dans la
vie vous avez sans doute votre propre
méthode pour avoir confiance en vous vos
croyances et bien moi j'offre à des
millions de gens le moyen d'y arriver
je suis la voix je dirigerai je ne
suivrai pas
je croirais je ne douterai pas je
créerai je ne détruirai pas je suis une
force du bien
je suis un leader repousse ses limites
créé de nouvelles exigences
lève toi lève toi
lève toi
l'an dernier mais cérémonie animée par
tony robinson lui ont rapporté la
bagatelle de 100 millions d'euros
et cette année il espère faire mieux
[Musique]
parmi les expériences que tony robbins a
popularisé la marche sur le feu depuis
plus de quinze ans l'association sound
organise elle aussi des stages de
motivation partout dans le monde
nous voici en californie en compagnie de
50 stagiaires venus d'europe pour
devenir à leur tour des instructeurs la
principale technique de motivation c'est
la marche sur des braises à 600 degrés
alors l'explication scientifique reste
controversé mais le principe de la
motivation lui est très simple posez les
pieds sur des braises provoque un
sentiment de terreur vaincre cette
terreur motive elle dynamise et du locle
doit stimuler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis des milliers d'années dans toutes
les cultures on a toujours marché sur
des braises pour être en relation
directement avec l'au delà
c'est quelque chose qui est proche de
l'état de grâce cela rend plus fort et
c'est cette sensation que j'essaye de
retrouver à chaque fois mois j'enseigne
la marche sur le feu mais je ne le fais
pas pour de l'argent ni pour le pouvoir
personnel ni pour vous aider dans votre
carrière
mais pour vous permettre de maîtriser le
pouvoir de votre esprit notre caméra m'a
lui-même a marché sur ce lit braise et
will nous voulions savoir comment et
pourquoi marché sur le feu était
possible ce résultat étonnant il faut
bien le dire
aucune brûlure ni même sensation de
chaleur la marche sur le feu a changé ma
vie
quand je me fixe un but quelque chose
que je veux vraiment faire dans ma vie
le feu augmente démultiplie ma volonté
quand j'ai commencé il ya trois ans avec
mon esprit cartésien je n'y croyais pas
et pourtant ça marche
et comme ça marche je continue à le
faire tandis que des coachs comme tony
robinson idolâtrait en occident les
chinois eux se cherche de nouveaux
leaders
et oui la chine a bel et bien changé en
s'ouvrant sur l'extérieur le pays a
découvert la publicité l'argent la mode
autant de reflets d'un monde qu'il ya 20
ans encore était interdite bannis et
considérés comme des cas dans vaincre
l'appréhension des chinois pour le monde
extérieur
c'est justement la mission de cet homme
pressé dans cette salle de pékin
donc ça ferait un motivé plus d'un
millier de personnes qui ont tout payer
20 euros pour assister à un cours
d'anglais un peu spécial un vrai show
que l'on s'arrache dans toute la chine
destinés à fabriquer des chinois
décomplexée m les asiatiques sont
extrêmement timides ils ont peur de
faire des erreurs de parler c'est pour
ça que je dois les encourager en leur
expliquant que s'ils veulent réellement
parler anglais
il faut qu'ils osent s'exprimer il fasse
travailler les muscles de leur bouche
ils ont des muscles chinois il faut que
ça devienne des muscles internationaux
résultat en six ans les yang est devenue
une véritable star en chine
sa méthode désinhibée ses élèves en les
faisant hurler en les forçant à
s'exprimer avec leurs corps un vrai défi
dans un pays où perdre la face se
ridiculiser est considérée comme une
humiliation suprême
pourtant les yang a déjà fait crier
débit longue chinois avec à chaque fois
entre deux mots d'anglais le même
discours nationaliste si j'avais dû
pouvoir
j'encouragerais la fermeture des chaînes
télé de divertissement pour les
remplacer par des chaînes éducatif
il n'y a que comme ça qu'on peut sauver
la nation
coca cola mcdo et microsoft ont réussi à
conquérir le coeur des chinois en dix
ans et les américains eux combien de
marque chinoise est ce qu ils
connaissent tout le monde dit waow le
21e siècle est celui des chinois mais
moi je vous dis qu'on doit encore
travailler dur pour y arriver
lions gate adapté aux étudiants du 21e
siècle il est plus vivant
j'aime bien sa manière d'enseigner
c'est pas comme dans notre école c'est
pas rigide c'est pas comme nos profs
d'anglais
eux ils ne parlent que de grammaire et
pour enfoncer prix est bien faire
comprendre aux chinois qu'ils n'ont pas
de complexe à avoir par rapport au monde
extérieur liant il fait toujours appel
un complice étrangers qu'il malmène
gentiment devant un public ravi
j'ai entendu dire que quand on parle
anglais en france on n'est pas bien
accueilli les français préfèrent parler
en français ouais c'est vrai vous voyez
bien qu'ils ne sont pas plus à l'aise
que vous
et loin de toutes ces considérations se
sont développées à pékin des soirées
consacrées à la musique punk presque une
hérésie dans un pays qu'il ya quelques
années en retard été jetés en prison ces
jeunes marginaux caron d'une figure
locale s'en félicite
quand on a découvert les punks on a tout
de suite aimé ce style on s'en fout que
ce soit occidental ou oriental on a aimé
c'est tout pourquoi ça n'existait pas
avant
parce qu'avant le gouvernement chinois
l'interdisait mais c'est fini tout ça
ce soir le groupe devient rôle doit
jouer ici orapi paradise
la patronne du lieu est l'une des rares
accepté de programmer des concerts peur
pour moi c'est du business je ne
m'occupe pas politique
maintenant dire ce qu'on pense n'est
plus un crime
ces jeunes disent qu'ils ont sur le
coeur tout simplement pour les fans de
kia aux ronces et l'exutoire les espaces
de liberté en effet comme celui là ne
sont pas encore nombreux en chine
alors on en profite on se défoule avec
son corps bien sûr mais aussi avec les
mots
kamel en tordant drôle
tous les maillons les bons
m
voilà
[Musique]
bacquet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]